c'est une marche arrière spectaculaire
que roussel uclaf le groupe
pharmaceutique a annoncé aujourd'hui
c'est aussi un recul dans la
modernisation des méthodes pour
interrompre volontairement des
grossesses non désirées
il ya moi je vous l'avais annoncé le
ministère de la santé avait autorisé la
mise sur le marché d'une pilule abortive
improprement surnommée pilule du
lendemain dont l'utilisation était
d'ailleurs limité au centre spécialisé
depuis des groupes de pression surtout
catholiques en france et à l'étranger
faisait campagne contre ce nouveau
produit ou celle du claf a préféré
abandonner le marché
jean daniel flaysakier daniel voici la
désormais fameuse ru486 cette pilule
aujourd'hui objet de scandale est
appelée parfois à tort pilule du
lendemain
son principe c'est d'empêcher le
développement de l'embryon dans l'utérus
son efficacité supérieure à 95%
lorsqu'elle est associée à des
prostaglandines qui déclenche des
contractions de l'utérus
premièrement c'est un médicament à part
entière c'est dire qu'il a subi tous les
contrôles et les avis nécessaires y
compris celui du comité d'éthique en 87
avant d'être autorisés sur le marché il
ya seulement un mois
deuxièmement c'est un médicament qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la loi sur
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
c'est-à-dire qu'ils supposent des
garde-fous médicaux uniquement prescrit
dans les centres d'orthogénie est
administré en présence d'un médecin
après un délai de réflexion de huit
jours inondé quotidiennement de lettres
de menaces de mort contre ces cadres
oursel va donc provisoirement suspendre
la mise à disposition du produit en
france ce qui on s'en doute divise
encore un peu plus adversaires et
partisans de l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse
nous disons clairement le ru486
représente une menace grave malgré les
fragile barrière qui ont été élevés
un nouveau seuil de la banalisation de
l'avortement vient d'être franchie le
problème de l'interdiction de cette
pilule est un problème qui est un
révélateur d'un état de notre société
aujourd'hui où l'église dans sa
hiérarchie cléricale entend faire la loi
alors que répétant le avortement ou
pilule
aucune femme
que ses convictions religieuses
philosophiques ont politique empêcherait
de pratiquer d'utiliser la télé ni
contrainte de le faire de même le groupe
va suspendre ses démarches pour lancer
le produit aux états unis en amérique du
sud dans ces pays en effet de puissants
lobbys anti avortement menace de
boycotter roussel or la filiale
américaine de russel préparait le
lancement d'une série de produits
majeurs comme la roxy trop missiles un
antibiotique très important pour le
groupe ou aussi des produits destinés au
traitement du cancer de la prostate des
médicaments au chiffre d'affaires
potentiel énorme comparé à ceux du et
rue économiquement donc le retrait du
ru486 ne devrait pas pénaliser un groupe
qui a semble-t-il bien d'autres fers au
feu